and I'm just merging on to this highway
driving like you know 10 15 miles an
hour and all of a sudden boom I just get
rear-ended and look there's like this 18
wheeler it's like there's no way you
didn't see me I didn't whip into his
Lane I wasn't being that you know the
truckers hate when the cars like don't
respect him and cut them off and like I
wasn't even doing that I was just
gradually going in he just bangs into
the back of my gun just keeps going
so I'm like what the I'm looking at
him and he gives me like the peace sign
so I think he meant I'm out of here so I
got his license plate so I call the
9-1-1 they're like you know kind of like
what exit it happened on and you do this
you fire report do you have his license
plate I got his license plate and he did
this he did and I just said all right
all right forget it if you just pulled
over and gave me his side I would just
be like all right do you know I don't
want to go through all this you
it I don't care all right